>> Tucker: WELCOME TO "TUCKER
CARLSON TONIGHT."
THE NEWS OUT OF THE DOMINICAN
REPUBLIC GETTING WORSE BY THE
DAY.
AMERICANS IN DANGER THERE.
NOW AN AMERICAN BASEBALL LEGEND
IS IN THE HOSPITAL TONIGHT.
EVEN FOX'S OWN NEWS CREW CAME
UNDER ATTACK.
THIS SHOW WAS ON THE GROUND FOR
AN INVESTIGATION.
A LIVE REPORT MINUTES AWAY.
FIRST, YOU PROBABLY DIDN'T READ
ABOUT IT BUT IT LOOKS LIKE THE
PRESIDENT'S BRINKSMANSHIP WITH
MEXICO WORKED.
HE WAS GOING TO IMPOSE TARIFFS
UNTIL MEXICO JOINS US TO FIGHT
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS.
THEY WILL NOW DEPLOY 6,000
TROOPS ON THE BORDER AND ASYLUM
SEEKERS WILL WAIT IN MEXICO THAN
IN THE U.S.
THAT WON'T SOLVE OUR ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTION PROCESS.
YOU WOULD THINK EVERY AMERICAN
WOULD BE HAPPY.
NO DEMOCRATS COMPLAINED AND TOOK
MEXICO'S SIDE.
>> THEY ARE OUR ALLIES.
WE SHOULD NOT CONFRONT THEM.
TRUMPS ERRATIC THREATS ARE NOT
THE WAY TO GO.
>> THE TARIFFS IN GENERAL, I
THOUGHT WHAT HAPPENED WITH
MEXICO AND THE WAY HE USED THAT
ON THE IMMIGRATION ISSUE WAS
JUST NOT A GOOD THING.
>> I THINK THE PRESIDENT HAS
COMPLETELY OVER-BLOWN WHAT HE
PURPORTS TO HAVE ACHIEVED.
THE PRESIDENT ACHIEVED NOTHING
EXCEPT TO JEOPARDIZE THE MOST
IMPORTANT TRADING RELATIONSHIP
THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA
HAS.
>> Tucker: IF YOU ARE TRYING TO
FOLLOW THE REASONING AT HOME:
BY ASKING MEXICO TO STOP
ENCOURAGING AN ILLEGAL INVASION
OF OUR COUNTRY WE ARE
JEOPARDIZING OUR RELATIONSHIP
WITH MEXICO AND IT'S OUR FAULT.
THE DUMBEST AND MOST EXTREME
RESPONSE CAME FROM BOOKER AT
ENGINEER.
-- NEW JERSEY.
HAVING A BORDER AT ALL IS LIKE
MURDERING PEOPLE DURING THE
HOLOCAUST.
>> THERE WAS A SHIP THAT CAME
HERE DURING WORLD WAR II WITH A
BUNCH OF FOLKS TRYING TO ESCAPE
THE HOLOCAUST AND WE TURNED IT
AROUND AND THEY GOT KILLED.
YOU WOULD THINK WE WOULD LEARN
OUR LESON ABOUT PEOPLE COMING
HERE TO ESCAPE TERROR.
>> Tucker: HOW DO YOU RESPOND TO
THAT?
I THINK IT'S BEST TO IGNORE IT?
WHAT DID YOU CONCLUDE?
YOU ASSUME DEMOCRATS LIKE
IMMIGRANTS.
THEY DON'T.
WHEN IMMIGRANTS ARE PRO-AMERICAN
AND CALLED TO FOLLOW OUR LAWS,
THE LEFT TURNS ON THEM TOO.
IT'S HAPPENING RIGHT NOW TO A
PROFESSOR WHO IS A LEGAL
IMMIGRANT FROM CHINA AND OPPOSES
ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION.
TOMORROW NIGHT HE WILL JOIN US
ON THIS SHOW.
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY DOESN'T
WANT MORE IMMIGRANTS LIKE HIM.
THEY WANT IMMIGRATION BASED ON
FAMILIES AND NOT MERIT?
FOR THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY, THE
LESS SKILLED THE IMMIGRANT IS,
THE EASIER TO CONTROL.
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THE
GOVERNMENT IS PLANING TO SPEND